[Music]  I'm starting out live you did many  impressions you're very good at doing  impressions of different divas yeah and  and IRA always really loved your Oprah  impression that's someone you don't want  to piss off like not at all  we did a spoof on Oprah's Favorite  Things right um she did have me come on  and she she said she really liked it she  said she really appreciated that I was a  woman like because I think I was the  first woman on Saturday Night Live to  play her like it was always played by  you know Tim Meadows and Tracy dinner so  she was just she lived in a - thank god  you're not a dude I haven't heard from  her since  right but the first time yes she really  likes a displeased Oprah you'd know it  I think old robots would show up at your  door you get a minute Harpo production  it just says that on where the robot  piece that's the last year who dies  Harpo Productions many right  your death has been a Harpo production